>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Steve Antosca: Going
to give a presentation
about percussion composition that
I created with my two colleagues,
William Brent and Ross Karre.
And before we get started I want to
thank all the folks at the Library
of Congress for inviting us here.
And it's a great honor for
us to give this presentation.
And we have a lot to cover so I'm
just going to jump right into it.
This is a breakdown of what
we're going to do this afternoon.
I'm going to talk about some
of the compositional elements
behind creating Habitat,
and some of the history behind it.
William Brent is going to
talk about the technology
that he created for the piece.
And Ross is going to talk
about video aspects of it.
Then we're going to
take a brief break
for about five minutes while we
get set up for the performance.
And Ross and William are then
going to perform three movements
from Habitat, the opening, which
is what you see in the center here,
and then third movement called
household, which is on the far side,
and then triangles,
which is in the front.
So this piece, Habitat, was
written for the 35th anniversary
of the east building of the National
Gallery Art and was also part
of the 65th Annual Music Festival.
And this came about because
I had created a concert
for the 70th anniversary of the west
building of the National Gallery,
and the gallery asked me
to compose a new piece
for the 35th anniversary
of the east building.
And knowing the space very
well I immediately thought
about a piece I had
conceived of around 2005
that involved a percussionist
wandering through a kind
of spiral galaxy of
percussion instruments.
And as he moved through
these instruments more
and more technology
was added to the piece
to add certain levels of complexity.
And the piece kind of laid
dormant for several years,
but when I was invited to create
this piece for the east building,
to create a piece, I
immediately thought of Habitat.
And William and Ross and I sat down
for about 2 1/2 years and mapped
out all the parts of it,
and thought out strategy
of how to create the piece.
And as I said, I'm going
to tell you a little bit
about the composition
components of it.
I'm going to talk specifically
about four parts,
what I refer to as transformations,
the architecture and the space,
the percussionist's
path, and finally,
score design, structure and time.
And these were the four
elements of the composition
that I decided were critical
to make to realize this piece,
to make it into what I was thinking.
So first of all, transformation.
I was thinking about three
elements that were important
to make the concept of
transformation happen.
First of all, thinking of music
as a -- as an abstract language.
It's unique in that it
can create abstract images
for the listening audience.
Then the second is the
transformational power of music.
And the third is music as sound
composed across a time canvas.
And I'll talk more
about the third one
in detail toward the end of my talk.
So, first of all, music as a
singular abstract language.
I've always been fascinated by
the abstractedness of music.
You can make it whatever you want
and different people perceive
what you create differently.
And music not like words and speech.
You need to be able to comprehend
what someone is saying in order
to have a conversation with them.
As an example, if you were having
a conversation with someone --
if someone is speaking to you in a
foreign language and you don't speak
that language, you can't
comprehend what they're telling you.
Whereas with music, you --
in order to understand it
at a very high level you
generally are trained in some way
as a musician, but that might
not affect your enjoyment
or appreciation of music.
You don't have to be trained
as a musician to understand it
or enjoy it or get
pleasure out of it.
So because of its abstract
nature you can do a lot of things
with music that can be
appreciated hopefully
by a wider range of people.
And, for me, the -- all art has to
be transformational in some way.
That's the real power behind art and
the -- and the power behind music.
And what I was attempting
to do with Habitat is
to use the performance base to blend
acoustic sounds of instrument --
of the percussion instruments,
technology, and the architecture
of the space to create a
transformational affect.
And I've wanted to do this
not just for the person --
the audience listening, but
for the percussionists as well.
So in Habitat the performer goes
through this transformational
journey, which I'll describe
in a little bit, but it also is one
that hopefully the
audience enjoys as well.
And this element of music composed
across a time canvas is one
that is very important to me.
I -- all of my music is very
deliberately mapped out,
and I'll show you some examples
later, and it is very specific
in terms of the timings
and how its performed,
even when there are
aleatoric sections
of it there are boundary conditions
that the performer has to adhere
to in order to play that part.
So after I thought about all
of these transformative forces
for Habitat, I came up with this --
what I refer to as the Habitat
transformation algorithm.
And it consisted of three parts,
the composer, the percussionist,
the computer musician,
and architecture.
So each of these characters
has a unique role to play.
The composer creates the source
material, or the seed idea.
And essentially the composer
puts all of this on paper
and designs the entire piece, but
it's the percussionist in this case
who makes the piece come alive.
The percussionist realizes
these black smudges
on these dots on a piece of paper.
So it's critical for the
percussionist to be able to sort
of own the piece and give life to
what the composer puts on paper.
In the case of Habitat and all
other computer music, it --
the role of a computer
musician is --
opens up a new threshold
where new sounds are created,
and ideas that the composer has
and that the percussionist
performs are taken to a new level.
And the -- with Habitat the
percussionist acts as a trigger
for some of these sounds,
and the computer musician,
in this case William Brent,
modifies the incoming sounds
and also generates some
new sounds for the piece.
And all of this happens
within the context
of the architecture of a space.
And in the east building
of the National Gallery
there is voluminous space.
It's really an extraordinary
place to perform a piece of music.
And I have some pictures that
I'll show you later of layout.
And our challenge was to put
all of these pieces together
and make them coherent
inside a monstrously huge
architectural space.
So that leads me to this
part, architecture and spaces.
This is the east building of the --
the east building atrium of
the National Gallery of Art.
And if you -- if you've
never been there,
it's really an extraordinary
place to visit.
And it's a fabulous place for art.
And we were very privileged
to be able to present --
to premier Habitat in this
beautiful space and to be allowed
to explore the sonic
possibilities in the atrium.
So knowing that we were going to
present Habitat in the atrium,
I felt what needed to
happen is that we needed
to create a sonic ecosystem.
And I developed a set of
parameters that we needed to explore
to make this happen, and the first
was thinking about the architecture
of the space as a kind
of inverted sculpture.
And when we presented Habitat
we had multiple workstations,
performance stations
as you see here.
And these work beautifully
in the atrium.
They look like pieces of artwork,
sculptures that were
inside the atrium.
So we also -- I have done a number
of performances inside the atrium.
And I was -- I spent a lot of time
before the performance of Habitat,
and before composing it,
listening to the space,
walking around the space,
actually bringing speakers
into various places and corners
of the space and projecting sound
to find out what it sounded
like in all the various spaces
and areas of the atrium.
And I also recognize that there
would be two kinds of participants
in this, the creators,
that is William, Ross,
and I in this case,
and the audience.
And what we needed to do was
to shape a unifying experience
through our creativity and connect
with the audience and have them go
on this journey with
the percussionist.
So this is just a kind of shopping
list of things that I was thinking
about for the creative side of this.
I won't go through this list, but
you can take a quick look at them.
And they're very ordinary
things, like being concerned
about speaker placement, the
movement of the performer
through the space, but also the
more important one was auditory
spatial awareness.
That is, the three of us spent time
in the space thinking about how
to set things up and what would
work best for the performance.
Also, the final one,
vertical and horizontal
and surround sound
was very important.
We weren't thinking of this in
terms of a traditional performance
in a space like this where sound
is projected right at the audience,
but rather we wanted to
surround the audience with sound.
We wanted sound to be
able to move vertically
as well as move at the audience.
And the audience's role was
obviously a lot more static.
We wanted to have the audience
respond to the performance,
and in some performances I've done
in the atrium we've actually
asked the audience to move
around to listen to the performance
from different perspectives.
And so the audience is --
inhabits the sound space.
And that was one very
important goal for us.
We wanted the audience
to feel like they were
within this massive instrument
that we were creating.
And so I recognize that
the best way to do this was
to have a solo performer,
not to write a piece
for multiple performers because I
wanted the focus of the audience,
the listener, to be on
one performer's journey
so that they always knew that
sound was either being triggered
in some way or created
by the percussionist,
or by some processing that's
being done to that performer.
So there were -- it's not
perception that who was --
who was responsible for creating
the sound and the performance
so they could focus
on one performer.
And this idea led me to something
that I call the multiplicity
of effects.
And I'm very interested in blending
all of these sounds together.
When you think about
any performance,
just a regular acoustic
instrument performance,
what you're really hearing
is the acoustic instrument
and that instrument in the
space it's being performed in.
And if you think about
performances that you've heard
in difference venues, the instrument
can sound very different depending
on the shape and the design,
the architecture of that space.
So what we were attempting to do
is blending the acoustic instrument
through traditional
performance techniques.
You'll Ross play these instruments
in very traditional ways.
You'll also see him play
them in nontraditional ways,
what we refer to as extended
performance techniques.
Then there's also computer
processing,
which will be very obvious to.
And then the effect, the impact
of the architecture of this space.
So this is what I refer to as
the multiplicity of effects.
Then finally, computer music
technology, these are the things
that the three of discussed
and wanted
to create, and William realized.
So we were able to set up a
multi-channel computer system
and it's all controlled
through William's computer.
There's also real-time computer
processing that's happening
and percussion samples that are
modified and advanced by William
and played during the piece.
And then, as you will hear during
the performance part of this,
there's spatialization control
through the computer, but also,
you won't see this today, but in
the performance in the atrium,
as Ross performed the piece
and moved around the hall,
the sound sources were coming
from different directions.
So that leads me to the next part,
which is the percussionist's
path through the atrium.
So once again, this is the
atrium of the east building.
And after I decided I was going to
write Habitat I spent a lot of time
in the space wandering around
all the areas that you see here.
And I created this
diagram to create --
to map out what I thought
of as a spiral galaxy,
where you see down in
numbers one and seven,
this is the starting
and the ending point.
And Ross moves from there to number
two and three, and the number four,
five, and then six is the bridge
up at the top of the atrium.
And then he moves over to
the left side of the screen
and there's actually a hidden
elevator back there, which he takes
down to the floor to
finish the piece.
So I've got some images of
-- before I get to those.
These are the seven
movements of Habitat.
And then after -- between
six and seven you can see
that there's a little prepared
piano interlude, and I'll explain
that in a -- in a moment.
We're going to perform sections one,
three, and six in a little while.
So this is what the opening
and closing section look
like on the floor of the atrium.
So Ross started out
from this position.
And you can see these
beautiful images he projected.
There are three projectors, one
under the bridge on the left side,
and then one on the far wall,
and one on the near wall.
And if you look at the far right
of that image you can see the
third station, the flower pots.
So this is the opening.
You then move a piano that was
used as a percussion instrument,
treated as a percussion instrument.
He's playing the inside
of it in this section.
Then this is a Harry Bertoia
sculpture that was in the atrium
at the time of the performance.
And we received permission from
the National Gallery to allow Ross
to play it, and you can see he's
wearing white gloves and he has
to run his hands across these rods.
These are, I think,
17 foot long rods
and they made absolutely
gorgeous sound.
And so when he was moving from
the second station, the piano,
to the third station, which
is the household station,
he walked passed this and
just moved it with his hands,
and it actually rang and
played for several minutes.
And then this is the stairway up to
the third station, the flower pots.
Here's a close up of
Ross playing those.
And that's one of the sections
he's going to play in a little bit.
Then he moved on to sound modules.
And it -- the flower pot section he
plays in a very traditional manner,
but he's playing unusual
percussion instruments.
And in this section, sound modules,
he's playing traditional
percussion instrument
but he's triggering them
in a very unusual way.
You see in his left
hand he has a microphone
and he's playing something
called proximity,
moving the microphone
closer and further away
as he activates all
of these instruments.
Then he moves up to the triangles
at the highest point in the atrium.
Here's a close up of that.
And so we had this issue of Ross
having to walk across the bridge
and get in the elevator
to come down to the floor,
and that took about a minute or so.
So there was a -- I wrote a
short prepared piano part,
and the piano sort of
snuck out from the audience
and played this part
while he was walking
across the bridge and coming down.
And you can -- this is the
image of a short moment
where the two of them
played together.
And then he plays the
closing section here.
So this is a map showing
all the different stages
that he moved through, from
the floor up to the stairs
to the mezzanine, and
up to the bridge,
and then back down to the
floor again for the closing.
So knowing that the piece was
going to be mapped out like that,
I began work on the score design.
And for me, the two
most important elements
in creating a score
are structure and time.
And structure is important to
me because it creates a set
of boundary condition that allow me
to feel comfortable
writing the piece
and knowing exactly how long
the piece is going to be
and what all the performance
elements are going
to be in the piece.
So I actually create very
tightly controlled structures.
I will show you some examples of
the opening section in a moment.
The other element that's
important to me is time,
and being very tightly
controlling of the time element.
And these are two of my favorite
sayings about the time element.
Time if the canvas on which you
consider music to be presented.
And this one, by the same
composer, Elliott Carter,
the really interesting thing
about music is the time of it,
the way it all goes along.
And I feel exactly the
same way about these.
These are really -- time is
the most important matter
to control in a composition.
So one of the things that I
created was a map that shows,
if you look across the top you can
see these seven galaxies that I --
as I refer to them, and each of them
have different sets of instruments
and they show dynamic progressions
and all the various
other progressions
that are happening in
the -- in the piece.
This is a close up of the first
half of the -- of the -- of the map.
And here's the second
half, and I want to point
out at the bottom this quote
from William, that when earlier
on in our discussions about
creating Habitat this was --
this was what William stated as
his intention for the electronics
and the computer part of it.
And I think we really
succeeded in creating that.
So I have all of these
-- I have a map of the --
of the venue of the space.
I have a kind of time
map of how I'm going
to move percussionists
through the space.
And then I start to work
in very specific units,
something that I call --
refer to as sonic units,
and start breaking the piece
up into manageable units.
And across the time at the
top you can see the timeline
through the piece.
And I don't -- when I say
timeline I don't mean minutes or,
I'm talking about seconds that
I'm going to be working on.
Then I made a list of them in
the center of it and trying --
I'm trying to order them
here in the lower half of it.
And so from this not very
detailed timeline I start
to build more detail into the piece.
Start to work on dynamic
levels and what's going
to happen with the computer parts.
And then across the top here you
can see there are tonal centers
that I'm working on, that I'm
figuring out, and what's going
to happen in these various states
for the computer and the performer.
And this is another
breakdown of the opening.
And there's a lot to absorb here.
You couldn't possibly absorb all
of this, but I want to show you
that I'm breaking this down into
more and more detail and start
to figure out specifics
about each section and neater
and important factors like that.
And eventually I put
all of this together
into a very specific
timeline that looks like this.
So this is -- this is a
timeline of the opening section,
which is about 10 minutes,
and it maps almost every event
that's supposed to happen
and breaks everything down
into very precise segments.
When the computer is supposed to
happen, when Ross is switching
from instrument to instrument.
And so it's a very,
very specific breakdown
of how the first movement
is going to go.
And this actually does
eventually turn into music.
And this is the -- this is the score
for the -- for the opening section.
And each of the movements has
a quote associated with it.
And this one is from Steve Schick's
book, The Percussionist's Art.
So all of these -- all the sections
that you're seeing through here,
the meter changes and instrument
changes and the phrasing changes,
are all mapped out in
the section before.
So this is still the -- this is the
second page of the opening section.
And Ross is going to play
this for us in a little bit.
So I think that we were
very, very successful
in accomplishing what
we set out to do.
And this is a review that
Stephen Brookes wrote
in the Washington Post I
think a day or so after the --
a day or so after the performance.
And one of the things he points
out at the end is that it seemed
as if Ross is playing and
the atrium itself is a
gigantic meta-instrument.
And that was really my
goal, to make it feel
like the audience was inside this
sonic environment that we created
through the percussion,
through the movement,
and through the technology.
And so, again, Ross is going
to perform these three sections
from the piece in a little bit.
So now William is going
to give a little talk
about some of the technology stuff.
And I want to thank
both William and Ross
for all the work they've done
today in making this happen.
And for me, one of the
most important things
about contemporary
composition is collaboration.
It's really what makes very
difficult music happen.
It's what allows it to be realized.
And I'm very fortunate to have two
enormously talented collaborators
in Habitat.
And this really was a joint effort.
So William is now going
to talk about this.
[ Applause ]
>> William Brent: Hi,
I'm William Brent.
And I'm going to pick up right
here and just talk a little
about the technology,
design, and management of how
to control all these
different elements.
As you can tell from some of
the pictures Steve was showing,
there's a lot -- there are a
lot of instruments out there,
but there are a lot of microphones,
projectors, other computers
that are networked together.
So there's a lot to cover there.
So I'll show you a stage plot,
a vocal piece in a second.
And then I want to get into
the process of how to design
and manage something this
big, because there are
so many changing elements constantly
that you can't possibly
do it all manually.
You really need computer power
and processing to be able
to pull this kind of stuff
off in live performance.
And also, I want to
say a little about how
that impacts the performer.
And then I want to show you
the programming environment
that the piece was realized
in, which is called Pd,
which is short for Pure Data.
And it's basically just a graphical
programming language that's specific
for manipulating media,
and especially audio.
But you can -- you can
technically make anything.
It's a computer language
just like [inaudible].
And so there we'll look
at audio analysis stuff.
I kind of gathered meaningful
information off the microphones
about what the performer is doing,
different kinds of musical processes
that the computer can do in
response to the performer,
some sound synthesis techniques
that we're using, and
also transformation.
So those are kind of like the
effects, like a wah-wah pedal
on a guitar or a fuzz distortion,
that sort of thing, but different.
So this is the overview.
I don't know how clearly you can
see it, but these different stations
that Steve was showing you
in the actual images are
kind of mapped out here.
You can see that there are
four mics on the opening
and closing section here.
That's what we've got set up
here, a couple on the piano.
There was a lavalier mic
for the household thing,
one on the modules thing that
Ross was moving his left hand
to capture those sounds, and
more on the triangles up here.
So all that has been fed into this
central audio computer that's taking
in all these channels of audio and
transforming them and then coming
up with the transform
result that's spatialized
over these eight speakers
here surrounding the space.
So we can really clearly make
the sensation of sounds moving
in specific directions,
sounds, you know,
happening in certain locations,
and sometimes just
having random processes
for controlling the spatialization
so that it's always kind of roaming
around and never settling.
The other main computer down
here is the video computer
that Ross' projection
design is run from.
So he created these videos.
He's going to say more
about that a little later.
And it's really important
though that the audio
and video computer are on
the same network together
so that we can send
information back and forth.
So whatever happens based on the --
what's coming in off the microphone
is going to affect the video,
things like changing the
brightness of the video
and how loud he's playing, or where
a note attack starts a new video
pops up, stuff like that.
So those are all connected
on a network switch as well
as two other computers for motion
capture to track Ross' gestures
as he plays, which can
also affect processing.
So a lot of -- a lot of elements,
and it is all controlled,
this is the terrifying
part, with one spacebar.
There are faders, of course,
too, for fine grain control,
but mostly that's automated.
If you take a peak later at
the equipment set up over here,
it's pretty minimal and it's just
some faders that are automated
as I move through these
pre-composed queues
that we worked hard
to get just right.
That's -- so that's where
I'll pick up to continue,
is what it's like to be able to
do this stuff in real time and how
that compares with the
way it used to be done.
There are some classic pieces from
the 1960's by Karlheinz Stockhausen
that involve electronic sounds
and acoustic instruments,
and they're played at the
same time in a performance.
But the big difference
between these two pieces here,
Kontakta has a fixed take part.
So its electronic sound
is recorded on tape
and you just hit play and you go.
And the performer memorizes all of
these wild sounds and knows exactly
where he or she is and plays their
part tightly, synchronized with it.
And the result is really
fantastic because you get --
you get these perfect moments
of these worlds coming together.
But the one drawback is, there's no
ability or leeway for the performer
to be able to be expressive with
things like phrasing and tempo.
They can't -- if they
want to rush a section
because they're just
feeling it in the moment,
they can't because they'll be out
of sync with this fixed take part.
One of the early solutions to that
was another piece by Stockhausen,
Mikrophonie I, that involves
exploring a giant tam-tam
with microphones but also has an
electronic instrument performer
that is controlling filters,
just a couple basic [inaudible]
filters, but in real time.
So that's another part in the score,
is how to move these
filters in real time.
So that works out great because they
can never get out of sync, right?
If the -- if the percussionist's
tam-tam performers go faster
or slower, the filtered
performer can slow down, too,
and it's just like any
other music situation.
So the problem is when you have
more than one person can do.
If you have instead of
two or three effects,
what if you have 200 effects,
and what if they change
much more quickly
than any person could
actually keep up with?
And that idea was explored
really effectively,
and still is being explored,
at [inaudible] in Paris
and some early pioneers there were
Phillippe Manoury, a composer,
and Miller Puckette, who's
the author of [inaudible],
these programming environments
for this kind of thing.
And they worked together to
develop a score following system
where the microphones analyze
what the performer is doing
to see what pitches they're playing.
The computer knows the pitches
they're supposed to play,
so if they more or less play their
part right the computer knows
where they are in the piece and can
make very specific things happen,
tightly synchronize with them.
And I've run -- these
pieces are amazing.
And I've run the electronics for
them myself, but I can tell you,
it's never perfect because
pitch tracking is not --
it depends on the instrument.
With percussion it's
especially bad actually.
And so there are problems with
it and you always end up having
to nudge the computer part along
and you're always terrified
that it's going to, you know,
jump forward five queues
and everything will be out of sync.
So what we've sort of settled
in on is just something
that's kind of semi-automatic.
Instead of an automated computer
part that just fully tries
to follow along with the
performer, we're having me,
or any computer musician, advance
the score along with the spacebar,
if you do a few other
minor adjustments,
something that's manageable
so that things can't
get too far out of sync.
And try -- we try to keep
the inner activity level high
by still using all that information,
the pitch and the loudness
and [inaudible] to actually
trigger events and processes
so that the whole result still
feels really interactive.
And actually I like that
graph that's [inaudible].
They're showing the feedback
loop between the performer
and the computer musician,
because obviously what Ross,
the percussionist is doing
affects what I do, and vice versa,
what I put back out into the space
is going to affect his playing,
just like you'd hope any kind of
chamber music situation would be.
So the next couple slides are
just to give you a little glimpse
into Pd, Pure Data, the programming
environment, which Pd does nothing.
You make everything in Pd
from basic elements basically.
It gives you basic tools like
math, multipliers and dividers,
and you can manage controlled data
for all the logic side of things,
and audio processing for
the audio side of things.
You can design, you know, effects.
So instead of -- if
some of you have worked
with digital audio workstations
where you have plugins,
someone made this plugin
or effect and you pop it in
and you can use it,
but you can't really --
there's a limit to how
much control you can have.
So the idea with Pd is to be able to
make anything you want from scratch.
So this is a screenshot from
the control panel for Habitat,
and you can see the different little
-- these are called sub-patches.
The main thing is called a patch.
And if you click into any one of
these you get one layer deeper
and you can go as deep as you like.
In here the processing module
has all of the effects.
And this DSB thing has
spatialization routines.
This involves network communication
to the other computers, you know,
by basic volume, all the -- all
the basic stuff you'd expect,
as well as controls for [inaudible],
which are all the specific queues
that happen through the
course of the piece.
This is just to show
you, kind of exploding
that other view, a
few layers into there.
So I'm not going to
show too much of Pd.
I'll show you a couple live
demonstrations in just a minute.
But basically you're interconnecting
a bunch of different basic objects
and programming your
whole system yourself.
These are little screenshots
from a couple --
this looks like a couple lines
from the opening section.
So on the left and right
are two different queues.
You can see like right
here I'm turning up the --
or turning down the time
stretch gain, on effects gain.
I preloaded a sample that
I want to be able to play.
I'm sending out a video queue
to Ross' computer for a change
in the video that's supposed
to happen right on that queue.
You can send spatialization
commands.
This is all just -- you can make up
your own language for how to talk
to your system and reduce it
into these basic commands,
which is nice because if you need to
make changes before a performance,
or you change your
mind, instead of having
to remember anything you just
go in like we did just today.
We wanted the release time on
some of these sine wave generators
to be longer, so I changed these
[inaudible] a couple hours ago
and we just made them longer.
So now those sine waves
are going to last longer.
And it's all really compact language
and it's actually manageable.
And that means every button press
when these commands are executed,
it could be 10 commands,
it could 100 commands,
but it's all instantaneous.
I'll quickly say a couple
things about audio analysis.
The big things that
we're taking advantage
of here are spectral
analysis, or foray analysis,
to get the spectrum of a sound.
And that can be done continuously
in little chunks of audio
as it's coming in off
the microphone.
So you can just take spectrum
snapshots and you can use
that information to capture things
like attacks, the spectral envelope
of the sound or how
bright it sounds.
You can also get volume.
You can get pitch off
of this spectrum.
And I wanted to show that
sort of in context here.
So this is a Pd patch here
that I made just to show this.
So this is me -- there's
the analysis
of me talking right now, right?
And you can see really
clearly, first of all,
this thing if we go
into the patch here.
I'm using a bunch of weird objects,
but this one gives you a text
that tells you when
there's been a sudden change
in the spectrum of a sound.
So if I snap my fingers
[snapping sounds], right,
it'll react really quickly.
And if I can make a bang, if
I can make an event happen,
I can make that button flash, then
I can do anything at that instant.
And it -- with the right settings
you can make it seem like as soon
as there's a note attack
the computer does something
at exactly the same
time, or close enough
to exactly the same time
that it feels together.
So that's one thing.
The spectrum itself, you can see
from me whistling right now maybe
[whistling], you can see energy
and different bands of the spectrum.
And when I'm talking you can
see harmonics of my voice
which could tell you
the pitch of the sound.
This is the pitch over
here [singing].
Right, it's graphing out pitch.
So all of this can be
done really cheaply.
It doesn't take much
processing power.
Okay. I think the next bit was just
to show you a couple of processes
that depend on that kind of
analysis in order to work.
So these are -- these aren't
effects processing the raw sound
of the instruments,
they're generated material
that the computer comes up with
independently, but it's triggered,
or at least controlled
by the percussionist.
So one of the ideas that
we talked about was this --
we call it a gesture trigger,
and the idea there was
to get any short phrase out of the
entire composition, which we encoded
in a certain way that
the computer can read it
and just grab a little phrase here,
a little phrase there any time
the percussionist hits a note
at certain -- at certain moments.
And that could be played back
using any samples we want.
So if we want to play that little
phrase using a vibraphone sound
or a [inaudible] sound or metal
instrument sound, we can do that.
And another one was the -- that
I want to show is the mobile.
And that was -- that happens
right at the end of the opening.
We're going to do it today.
And basically as the
performer goes through
and plays these specific
sounds at the end,
each one of those is
captured live by the --
by the computer and then just looped
at a different spot in the hall.
So it makes this collage of
spatialized sounds that sort
of accumulate as he
plays the material.
And we use that as transitional
material between the opening
and the piano section, which is the
next instrument he has to walk to.
So I'll just quickly show
little examples of those.
This is the gesture trig example.
[ Music ]
So there -- I think the
significant thing there is
that it's not just a computer
depending on the performer
and microphones to
generate something.
It can sort of hold its
own once he gets enough
of those little fragments
going and they play back.
It feels like it's got its own
momentum and then that can start
to create more of a push and
pull between the performer --
the live performer and the computer.
So that's sort of -- kind of
like a little additional player.
And this is the mobile that we're
going to hear in a moment anyway,
but I just want to draw
your attention to it
so that you understand how it's
being created when we play it later.
So you'll hear him play
these discrete events,
and let 30 seconds go by,
you'll kind of hear them echoing
and still remaining and
recirculating the space.
[ Music ]
Okay, I'll cut that off there.
So at the beginning there
were other processes going
on to [inaudible] decomposition
effect,
which I think will be the
last thing I show here.
But over all that's the challenge,
is to be able to make these
different layers of process happen,
not letting anything become
static and just sit there
for too longer that
it becomes boring.
That's the goal.
So I'll finish just by
showing you one more.
If any of you have studied physics
or foray analysis or anything
like that, or a lot
of musicians that get
into this have had some experience
with foray analysis and FFT's,
you could sort of appreciate
it what's going on here,
which is that any sound, I'm going
to use a recording of Ross playing
that we captured in a rehearsal,
but any sound coming in live
or recorded can be analyzed broken
down into its basic components
as sine waves because all sounds
are just a big sum of sine waves.
Even the sound of me
talking right now,
just really quickly
changing sums of sine waves.
If you have enough of them you
can perfectly resynthesize it.
So the idea here is to analyze
that using the analysis object,
which is called the Sigmund,
which is supposed to be a joke,
after Sigmund Freud for analysis.
And Sigmund creates -- it gives
you all of the frequencies, phases,
amplitudes of the main sine waves
and the sound you're analyzing.
You can tell it any
details you want.
Like right here I said I want to
know the 18 most important peaks,
most important sine components.
The highest I want to go is about
15,000 hertz, which is higher
than I can really hear anyway,
so I don't care that much,
and then some analysis specs.
And then all that information
is being sent
to a bunch of sine wave generators.
This is -- these are just
a bunch of sine waves.
In the end it's this, an oscillator,
just something that puts out numbers
that go like that, right?
But you can control the frequency
and the phase and the amplitude.
So this has about 90 oscillators.
Here's the real sound first.
I'll turn this up.
[ Music ]
And I'll mute that and
I'm going to start it over
and we'll hear the
synthesized version of it.
[ Music ]
You can kind of hear like little
[inaudible] weird sounds [music],
right?
Especially broadband sounds
like that tam-tam at the end.
But for a lot of sounds,
especially sounds that just ring
out like a vibraphone bar, it
can sound really realistic.
And for the triangles here that
we're going to work with later,
you can analyze that and
get all that information
and resynthesize it
really accurately
and make it sound pretty realistic.
But the point is not to synthesize
it perfectly but to get that level
of control and then do
something unusual with it.
So one of the effects
you'll hear a lot is this --
it's a set of commands to these
sine oscillators telling them
to start playing the right pitch
but then, you know, [inaudible]
and bend the pitch in weird ways
that just make the sound
sound like it's melting.
So if I play that same sample
with the different setting here we
can listen to that result [music].
And I'll mix in the original, too.
[ Music ]
Okay. We're going to hear a lot
more of that in the performance,
so I might just stop there.
But all of these things in a
nutshell just add another layer
of expressivity and
compositional intention,
and it's been great working
with Steve on this, and Ross,
because they're both -- all
of us have our foot in all
of these worlds, composition
technology and performance.
And so we really, I think, are
able to work together nicely
and communicate well to do this
kind of collaborative effort.
Okay, well I'm going to let Ross
say a little bit video here.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ross Karre: Thanks, William.
And thanks to Steve and also
the entire staff of the Library
of Congress for hosting this.
It feels nice to bring
the Habitat back to D.C.
In many ways it was born here.
It was created for the National
Gallery space, as Steve describe.
And we've had other performances
at the American University
Katzen Gallery.
And so I feel like this is --
this is the home, the
origin of this piece.
It's really nice to be back here.
And my main role in this project is
as a percussionist, but I also --
from the very beginning we started
to design what is now a common term
in theatrical and dance
productions and sometimes in music,
it's called projection design.
A subcategory of that is
called projection mapping.
And the basic idea was to bring
the sort of innards of this Habitat
that Steve created to
a much larger scale.
So the smallest, most micro-grain,
granular sort of element of the --
of the materials that go into making
these sounds, the piano strings,
the metals, the vibraphone bars, the
wood, all of the sort of textures
that comprise that sonic world,
we want to represent that visually
to allow kind of a microscopic
view into the sound world.
And what allows that is
instead of what we have here,
which is basically a very
presentational version
of projection, which is someone
talking and projected imagery,
we can -- we can design images that
integrate into the space itself.
We won't be doing that today,
but in the previous performances
we've had that opportunity.
And I want to show you a little
bit about what that field is,
not just for Habitat
but for the whole world
of theater and dance and music.
But what is projection design?
I think if you -- if
you -- we look at --
historically projection design
starts probably in the '60s
for what I call integrated media, or
intermedia, which was a term coined
by one of the Fluxus'
members, Dick Higgins.
And a writer around that time, one
of my mentors and collaborators,
Roger Reynolds, created
a piece in 1968.
It was my first experience
working with integrated media.
And what that means is essentially
what Habitat tried to do and does,
which is to take various
media components
and decide how they will each
serve one conceptual goal, focus.
In the case of this piece by Roger
Reynolds, the media were many.
There was a Butoh dancer.
Text by Samuel Beckett,
35 millimeter slides,
16 millimeter film projection,
quadraphonic electronic sounds,
percussion, harmonium,
piano, and flute.
And so for 1968 this was a lot of --
a lot of cables and a lot of
analog equipment to wrangle.
And my experience with the piece
was to bring it to the world
of the digital and make
it a digital piece.
It was through researching
this piece that I started
to understand the process
of integrating media.
And one of the most
interesting parts of that process
to me is this diagramming phase that
Steve and William both talked about.
So even in 1968 these sort
of diagrams start to crop up,
and so that you see that
composers are really starting
to consider space as one
of the parameters that's
as important as anything else.
It's as important as the
melody and the harmony
and the -- and the volumes.
And so this is an example of a 1968
version of a kind of stage plan
with the 16 millimeter
projector at the bottom
and the two slide projectors in
the middle and these two screens
that are represented by those
lines, and then the piano,
percussion, up in the upper left.
And then what happens over
the course of the history
of integrated media, of intermedia,
is we have a much more
sophisticated way
of managing these forces
in the diagram stage.
And for me it's one of the most
fun parts, is the creative part
of thinking about how screens can
be set up, what they'll be made,
where they'll be, whether
we're projecting on the walls
or base drum heads, or
whatever, it's a really fun,
creative part of the process.
So where this usually starts for
me, and it's the same for Habitat,
it's the same for all
the pieces I worked on,
is in a simple 3D rendering
software.
Sometimes I use this
software called SketchUp,
which is a little Google
offshoot, to create rudimentary,
three-dimensional abstract
representations, I guess, of --
geometric representations of
what the stage could look like.
And so not knowing what
all of these shapes mean,
it doesn't have much meaning
to someone outside the project,
but this was a design
for a three screen system
for James Dylan's piece.
James is known as a
Scottish composer
who writes really long
and complex pieces.
And during the sort of
premier of this piece we had
to come up with this design.
And it was realized in this form
you can see the three screens angled
in the lower left and upper right,
and in the middle screen
there's a base drum projecting --
protruding through it.
You can see the concept here
and then this is the
realization of the concept.
So the integration of those screens
is fundamental to the piece itself.
And it defines the piece's overall
environment and characteristics
and really sets it apart from a very
traditional sort of binary of actor,
singer, dancer, and screen.
Instead, it puts the
actor, the performer,
in the projected installation.
And so I've tried to do this with
nearly every piece I've created,
and Habitat is no exception.
In another version of the piece,
we often find ourselves requiring
a sort of site specificity,
which you've probably heard in the
sort of description of public art,
of site specific art, and some
spaces don't accommodate the same
installation twice.
And so I often end up
reinventing this integration
of media for each new space.
This is another version
of the same piece
with the same musical
instruments and the same sounds,
but a completely different
projection design that was more apt
to function correctly
in the space of this --
of this theater in the
Netherlands called the Bim House.
And the idea here was that the black
screen behind the circular base drum
screen in the middle
is actually looking
out over the harbor
and river in Amsterdam.
And so these sort of sail
screens become a nice foreground
to that backdrop.
So my main interest is in looking
at the space, and what the meaning
of that space -- what that space is
and integrating a screen
design that's complementary
or that's contrasting in a way
that creates its own conversation,
that makes for some sort of level
of interpretation from the audience,
in this case the motivation
was sails and ships,
and in this case the
motivation was to create --
to recreate the dry canal
beds of the Los Angeles River.
And in the case of -- you see here,
this is sort of behind the scenes.
This is the back view of the
sails in James Dylan's piece.
Some other images from
that same thing.
One of the largest productions I
worked on also had its origins here,
which is in the National
Symphony Orchestra's presentation
of a new piece called George
Washington, by Roger Reynolds.
And in this case we converted
the Kennedy Center space
into a three screen, 36 panel
array of images that were scaled
to the space and were designed to be
evocative of the inside of the top
of the Mount Vernon
mansion, Washington's mansion
on the Mount Vernon estate,
which is built of these panels
of windows in an octagonal cupola.
So we wanted to expand that cupola
and basically take the interior
of that and put that onto the stage
of the National Symphony's Kennedy
Center stage, which I'm sure some
of you -- some of you
here have seen.
And that sort of scale relationship
and the bringing of the orchestra
to that landscape of the Mount
Vernon estate was our way
of integrating the
concept and media.
That's my main -- my
main goal in all of this.
A couple other images from that
performance at the Kennedy Center.
And the newest project
I'm working on is trying
to do the opposite in scale.
Instead of big projections,
we're scaling everything
down to two by two foot boxes.
This is the initial
sketch up version
of the -- of the 3D rendering.
And here is an early
performance from March
of the string quartet sort
of situated in these --
this constellation
of two-sided boxes.
And the projections are mapped
precisely onto these surfaces.
And this is the part where
the actors come on stage
and they are situated
also among these boxes.
And the whole -- the whole
concept of this piece is based
on the history of flight from
sort of cave paintings of birds
to the entire history of
human aspiration to fly.
And so the images come
from that history.
They tell that story.
But the purpose of the boxes is
to create a vocation of box kites,
which is one of the original
ways of putting something in --
aloft in the air and it's
also the original conception
of the biplane wing from
the Wright brothers.
So that's the motivation
behind these boxes.
And over the course of the piece
that motivation gets revealed.
I like that idea that the
concept can be somewhat ambiguous,
can seem like abstracted cubes
at the beginning of the piece,
only to reveal as -- to reveal later
that it's supposed to be a wing.
And for Habitat, as you've
seen many images already,
the goal there again was to scale
up and to immerse the audience
in this world of microscopic imagery
from the materials of
the percussion setup.
And so for that process it
meant mapping huge projections
onto these facets of the stairwells
that lead to the lower level
and the upper mezzanine and the top
of the escalator of the east wing
of the National Gallery and
controlling them precisely
with the -- with the softwares
that William just described.
So the scale there isn't so much
about making my percussion playing
in the body somehow related to the
-- to the scale of the screens,
but instead you create a
wall of imagery that is --
that is all sort of
surrounding and encompassing.
For the -- for another performance
in the Katzen Gallery we didn't have
that luxury of creating such scale.
So for that we actually
went the opposite direction.
We created object-like projections
onto the smaller surfaces
of the -- of the -- of the setups.
So this is one of the setups.
You can see off to stage left
over here with the flowerpots,
and below there's this wooden
cube, and it's difficult to see
on this projection but there
are images precisely mapped
onto those facets of
that white gallery cube.
And similar, this was a
test setup of making sure
that the images would map onto
these other white gallery cubes
that served not only as percussion
instruments, like cajons,
but they also served as
something that's similar
and familiar to a gallery space.
So as not to impose a completely
foreign sculptural identity
onto the piece, we used
existing common resources
within the gallery itself.
And so that's the -- that's
where the piece has been.
It's transformed from this huge,
immersive piece that was all
about architecture and space,
to this object-oriented,
very focused version in the Katzen
Gallery at the American University,
and here today presenting a version
just for the three movements of --
with the live percussion playing
processed through electronic sounds,
without the video projections,
just to offer another version
of the piece, because every space
warrants a different interpretation.
And I consider space to be the
fourth collaborator of our quartet,
and that it has just
as big an impact
on the way we configure
this piece and interpret it
as any other consideration.
And so I think with that we
can move on to the second part
of the presentation, which
is a performance of three
of the movements of Habitat.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.